hay otra característica de los números
complejos que quiero compartir con
ustedes y lo veremos aquí abajo
nuestra definición de j es que j al
cuadrado es igual a menos 1 y ahora lo
que quiero hacer es una secuencia de
multiplicaciones de jota y es para
mostrar una propiedad importante de esta
unidad imaginaria vamos a calcular las
potencias de jota y las voy a graficar
en este plano complejo este es el eje
real este es el eje imaginario vamos a
encontrar las potencias de j
comenzamos con jota a la 0 y cualquier
número elevado a la 0 va a ser igual a 1
j a la 0 es 1 y si lo dibujamos en este
plano complejo va a estar aquí sobre el
eje real y nada sobre el eje imaginario
ahora jota a la 1 va a ser igual a jota
es j multiplicada por ella misma una
sola vez por lo que es igual a jota sí
gráfica moss este número va a estar por
acá sobre el eje imaginario no va a
tener componente real es completamente
imaginario
continuemos ahora nos toca encontrar
jota al cuadrado a que es igual pues lo
escribí aquí arriba jota al cuadrado es
igual a menos 1 donde ponemos esto en el
plano complejo pues acá menos 1 de este
lado y va a estar sobre el eje real no
tiene componente imaginario ahora
calculemos jota al cubo pues esto va a
ser igual a jota al cuadrado por jota y
estas dos las tenemos aquí arriba jota
al cuadrado es menos 15 está a la 1 es
igual a jota menos 1 por jota y es igual
a menos jota donde está esto en nuestra
gráfica pues va a estar aquí abajo en la
parte negativa de nuestro eje imaginario
no va a tener componente real tenemos
cuatro respuestas
encontremos un par más ahora tenemos
jota a la cuarta va a ser igual a jota
al cuadrado por jota al cuadrado y vemos
que es menos 1 x menos 1
que es igual a 1
vamos a graficar lo y vemos que ya lo
grafica mos está justo aquí
hagamos uno más jota a la quinta es
igual a jota a la cuarta por j
aquí tenemos jota la cuarta que es igual
a uno por jota por lo que es igual a
jota vamos a graficar lo y vemos que ya
lo tenemos aquí podemos ver que tenemos
un patrón aquí 1 j - 1 - j 1 j menos 1 y
menos jota se sigue repitiendo y aquí
viene lo interesante de esto si
dibujamos estos como vectores
si dibujamos a estos números imaginarios
como vectores cuando multiplicó por j
aquí uno por j
nuestro vector rota a 90 grados este es
el primer paso que teníamos aquí cuando
multiplique a uno por jota y me quedó j
cuando tuvimos jota al cuadrado
terminamos en menos uno por lo que
multiplicar de nuevo por jota causa que
nuestro vector rote o gire otros 90
grados si lo hacemos otra vez y
multiplicamos esto por otra jota
llegaremos a carl y el último nos lleva
hasta acá
esta es una propiedad clave de j
de esta unidad imaginaria el multiplicar
por la unidad imaginaria nos va a dar
esta rotación o este giro de 90 grados
cada vez es la idea de un número que
ocasiona que otros números giren o
rotten y esta es una característica de j
que la hace muy importante y es la razón
por la que usamos números imaginarios en
ingeniería eléctrica aquí la idea clave
es que j gira esto es lo que nos encanta
de j y lo último que quiero mencionar es
las potencias negativas de j qué sucede
con ellas si tenemos jota a la menos 1
va a ser igual a 1 / j
y si multiplico esto por jota entre jota
y cualquier cosa entre sí misma va a ser
igual a 1 por lo que no estoy
modificando el valor aquí y esto va a
ser igual a jota aquí arriba entre j por
jota jota al cuadrado a que es igual
jota al cuadrado pues lo tenemos por
aquí es igual a menos 1 por lo que esto
es igual a jota entre menos uno que es
igual a menos jota así que siempre que
veamos a jota en una fracción jota a la
menos uno básicamente va a introducir un
signo negativo y vamos a tener una jota
con signo negativo como resultado de
esta fracción así que jota a la menos 1
es igual a menos jota
y vamos a usar esto en ocasiones para
ayudarnos con la matemática así que este
fue un repaso rápido de los números
complejos y si algo de esto fue nuevo
para ustedes los invito a que vayan y
vean los vídeos que tenemos en cana acá
de mí sobre números complejos y si esto
es algo que ya habían visto pues espero
que les haya ayudado a desempolvar un
poquito estos conocimientos para estar
listos y usar estos números